la nôtre
beaucoup de malheurs un peu de bonheur
pour donner des faux espoirs
ça lui avait pris du temps mais mine de
rien c'était assez au point
mon père était arrivé un certain
d'accueil de virtuosité depuis il
passait ses journées à inventer une
nouvelle loi de l'emmerdement universel
watts 2005 la quantité de sommeil
nécessaire et de dix minutes de bus loi
2129 quand on plonge le corps dans la
baignoire
le téléphone sonne 2011 soit une tartine
de confiture ton toujours du côté de la
confiture
sinon c'est que la confiture est évident
du mauvais côté loi 2006 on ne casse la
vaisselle qu'après l'avoir la mère et la
fille d'à côté avance toujours dite loi
de 1200 trop-plein un emmerdement
n'arrive jamais seul